under this wants to stay in Hamburg the
man from Ghana has come a long way to
reach sankt pauli church and hopes his
journey will end here the 30 year old
college graduate couldn't find a job in
Ghana so we went to Libya when the
uprising against the Gaddafi regime
began he fled to Italy he spent two
years in refugee camps there until the
authorities said he had to go he came to
me and they said I will to close down
the program and so each and every ones
who take 400 euros to leave the program
in addition to the cash many of the 80
refugees in the church were advised to
head to Germany the visas they were
issued enabled them to travel across the
EU pastor zakat vilom noticed some of
them living on the streets in Hamburg
and offered to take them in you connect
on phone :
we can't just watch them wasting away on
the streets they're human beings with
basic needs and human rights these are
issues that have to be addressed if the
politicians close their eyes to the
matter then we have to open ours yawns
all definiteness is on fossil pasture
film founded and christened the Embassy
of hope on the church grounds his
mission of mercy has put him at odds
with the local authorities according to
EU law refugees arriving to Europe in
Italy have to apply for asylum in Italy
Gimenez a flokati of Italians when they
came here via Italy on tourist visas
valid for three months but after that
they have no right to a residence permit
so they have to go back just being vida
so for kin
Germany is a wealthy country in Hamburg
a wealthy city the city also has a
liberal tradition to uphold that
reputation could be strained due to the
300 refugees from Libya an information
tent publicizes their plight a banner
proclaims we didn't survive the NATO war
in Libya to die on the streets of
Hamburg they say the West is partly
responsible for their problem if we are
here we are not see a Europe by mistake
you know we are here because of
something who happen and they have to
open their eye and know that yeah
even their country is protein new good
Democrats for others and good ruling and
looma rights but there are countries who
have to do it not only pitch their
opinion is widespread in sankt pauli
it's famous nightlife district is also
home to a substantial left-wing scene
where the social democrat governments
refugee policy is under fire some
residents have decided to take action
they help the refugees by doing their
laundry bringing them food and money
the mosquitoes on this young it's about
the here and now and the help that can
be provided on the spot it's not about
some political point
what matters is seeing our neighborhood
functioning and I believe that's
possible here sunk Pauli is not the only
Church in the city to take in refugees
from Africa the local government fears
that granting them the right to stay
would encourage more to come
Hamburg already has 20,000 refugees who
came directly to Germany via homonym
book we have a lot of refugees coming to
Hamburg that means providing
accommodation for them and the city is
working to do that everyone knows the
refugee numbers are growing and there is
a need for action Deno vanish cata star
- 200 its current apathy and sed politic
talk about young we might see the
government change and say ok
we're letting you in and giving you a
special status you become turns on the
Star Tours veneer myself that would be
great I think there would be a massive
party here but at the same time we know
that it's pretty unlikely listen yeah
that's is relative one Russia something
that ondrea's and his fellow refugees
are all too aware of but they far from
given up the battle and their hopes of a
new beginning in Hamburg in the last six
months the number of asylum seekers in
Germany has almost doubled
you